after Steve Jobs and Tim Cook the most
recognizable face at Apple probably this
one Jonathan Ive Apple's chief designer
and the man behind products like the
iMac the iPod the iPhone the iPad and
recently iOS 7 Apple's latest mobile
operating system I doesn't strut around
on stage like a lot of other Apple
executives he's usually seen only in
videos and he very rarely gives
interviews except recently he gave one
to me and being that he is probably the
greatest industrial designer of his
generation I wanted to share some of his
comments with you the discoveries you
make when you are lucky enough to sit
next to somebody who represents a
completely different expertise those
discoveries can be really profound
apples not a terribly siloed
organization sure it has different
buildings but people tend to work in ad
hoc groups
I for example sits only one minute away
from Craig federighi Apple's chief of
software and often times the
distinctions between the two teams are
known only by HR I think we feel our job
is to try to solve tough difficult
problems but we don't make the
complexity of the problem apparent in
its resolution Ives philosophy is not
show your work the things his team works
on can be wickedly complex take these
animations in iOS 7 for example but to
the end-user they have to be dead simple
we feel that we've done our job when you
finally get to that point and you think
well there couldn't be a rational
alternative it appears inevitable it
almost appears like it wasn't designed
I've hear echoes the principles of
fellow industrial designer dieter roms
who designed products for Braun in the
60s 70s and 80s good design said roms is
as little design as possible
you